guys I have heard you I've heard your
voices and I've read the comment section
and I want to address a sentiment I've
seen reflected there no I will not shave
my mustache but in all seriousness this
video is going to address one of the
perspectives one of the opinions I've
seen not just in our comments section
but at the Internet at large about the
Tipu versus faze clan lawsuit and that
is that no matter how bad T Fu's
original contract may have been he
signed it and he should honor it well
his lawyer would disagree
[Music]
all right guys since our last video on
the Tifa vs. faze clan lawsuit there
have been a number of developments faze
clan came out and confirmed our
speculation on cloak C being on his way
out of the team
keemstar released a video where he got a
statement from faze clan that directly
addressed our last video on this topic
and heist guy came out with a diss track
music video that went weirdly hard at TV
it's all toilet sound now before we get
into the nitty gritty subject matter of
this video I do want to be transparent
with you guys this particular video was
supposed to be much longer and address a
number of different topics during the
production of it we got it we got an
interview with BAE's clan on the record
and that is going to come out Friday in
its own video dedicated just to that
we're gonna release net new information
on this case so stay tuned and hold on
to your butts now back to the subject
matter at hand some of you guys in the
comments section have expressed the
sentiment that T foo should honor his
contract no matter how bad it
quantifiably may have been when he
signed it no matter how immoral you may
think it is simply because he signed a
contract and he should honor you don't
fight with honor now from a moral ground
I can understand that perspective
although I personally don't particularly
agree not that that matters really
so I went back to T Fu's lawyer Brian
Friedman and asked him about this
sentiment and something that he really
wanted to get across to me when we spoke
about it is that from his team's
perspective from Teague perspective it
is not a case of t-through honoring a
bad contract it is a case of Teague
signing a contract that from the
beginning according to his team was no
void illegal and unenforceable so if
you're sitting around saying too bad you
signed it even if it was bad you're
missing the point because the point is
they weren't even allowed to use that
contract according to the law and
therefore it never should have been put
in front of him for him to sign which is
why the contract is illegal and void ab
initio meaning void from the start
because they did not comply with the law
this is not a question of oh gee this is
a bad deal certainly if the bad deal
there's no question there but that's not
the issue the issue is did them follow
the law and if they didn't follow the
law which I know to be true then that
contract is being void not void and
illegal because it's outrageous that
they would get 80% but void and illegal
because they didn't get a license to
actually operate to do the things that
they're doing the talent agencies do now
even after hearing that I'm gonna
presume that there are still quite a few
of you who are going to be on BAE's
clans side in this but let's make one
thing clear here this shouldn't be a
case of so-and-so got screwed over or
so-and-so is a snake this is a lawsuit
it's going to come down to a resolution
where one party or another comes out on
top based on the letter of the law
it's not about fandom it's not about
clout and it's not about views it's
about who is right under the law I
cannot tell you who that is I
only present to you the information as
best we get it it is balanced away as we
can if you are interested in hearing on
how faze clan themselves refute the
claims of the lawsuit and what kind of
legal and moral grounds they are arguing
for we're going to have that for you on
Friday when we release a full video
dedicated to our recent interview with
Lee trink CEO and co-owner of bass clam
so stay tuned for that
well T Foos lawyer would disagree
actually I'm pretty good I think I would
probably shave it but no in the intro
the intro and I didn't even pause and do
my normal intro what am i doing I don't
know what I'm doing alright
why I wanted you try it again anyway